all right let me just say that no one
should be dancing on the grave of
someone who just lost his job it is
terrible so for everyone laughing at
poor Brian stelter tonight I want you to
know that no job's ever safe everyone is
replaceable everyone makes mistakes even
me
Brian stetler here at CNN he's a beaut
didn't settlers maybe she can ask Brian
Stettler
you see it happens to the best of us
stelter frankly tonight I'm feeling a
little nostalgic about Brian
who was this well-known shoeless member
of the media I spotted on the train up
to New York yesterday uh it was in fact
CNN's Brian stelter at first I was
worried he was not amused by my ribbing
because he tweeted out hey I'll admit to
having sore feet if Laura admits to
taking creep shots for the record I did
not take that shot but someone on the
train did and they forwarded it to me
thanks for being a good sport Brian and
a polite request though for the sake of
social order
please even with those cute little
orange socks of yours please keep your
shoes on in public okay no bare feet no
bare feet on a train plane no we don't
want to see that all right best of luck
to you Brian we hope you land on your
bare feet hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else